but first my brain dump
when a comedian's joke doesn't land they
call it dying on stage but in today's
world it seems like that phrase could
soon become all too real
last night a netflix gig at the
hollywood bowl in la dave chappelle the
streaming company's biggest comedy star
was violently attacked by a man with a
replica gun as he went about his job
telling jokes
make some noise for hip-hop history
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes we seemingly now live in a world
where a comedian delivering punch lines
is seen as an open invitation to get
punched chris rock who always seems to
be around with these things happened
doesn't he came to chappelle's rescue in
the aftermath for calling his own
encounter with stage violence at the
oscars
was that will smith
[Applause]
well it wasn't will smith a lot of
people are drawing a connection between
the two incidents and i can see why but
here's the big difference to me the will
smith slap was basically an a-list
version of a blank punching another
bloke in the pub for insulting his wife
it wasn't the right thing to do but in
the heat of the moment we've all done
crazy things for love the fact is they
knew each other they had a history it
was personal the deeply troubling thing
about the attack on dave chappelle is it
seems to have been political we don't
know yet the exact motives for the
attack but we do know that chappelle's
been threatened repeatedly with
supposedly controversial jokes he's had
a long a successful career dissecting
issues like race and sexual politics in
america but his biggest fearless comedy
takedowns of the more extreme trans
activists on his recent netflix specials
that have made him a target for threats
of violence and left him fearing for his
family's safety
now i've called netflix wetflix for his
increasingly woke content of late but in
the case of chappelle i applaud them for
standing by their guy in the face of
staff walkouts aimed at getting him
cancelled the same things like gender is
a fact these militant misanthrops claim
that chappelle's edgy comedy is violence
but it's not it's free speech
violence is actual violence as we saw
last night and these are dangerous times
for comedians and for comedy if they
can't go about their business being
funny without fearing for their lives
now knows the trigger warning for
college and university students
[Music]
as i may clear when we launch this show
peers morgan on sunset is a free speech
event over the next hour you may
encounter opinions you don't agree with
it might have already happened you might
be watching me now i'm vehemently
disagreeing with me well guess what
that's the real world so get used to it
there is a brutal censorship gripping
our colleges and universities it's an
even more serious assault on free speech
than what's happening to comedians this
week the new york post reported on five
professors who've been attacked by the
cancer culture mob due to complaints
from students one philosophy professor
was barred from teaching his course
after students complained about him
using offensive language in a course
about the use of offensive language
think about that this is how ridiculous
it's all getting i applaud those
professors for speaking out at greater
risk again to their careers but what
kind of kids are we raising through our
colleges if they're only allowed to hear
one opinion these aren't isolated cases
it's a global sensitivity scourge caused
by simpering snowflake students you
think they're entitled to their opinions
and they can silence shame and cancel
anyone whose opinions that don't conform
to their narrow woke world view
a staggering 591 professors in the us
have reported retaliation in recent
years for expressing their views and we
see over and over again with invariably
conservative or feminist speakers being
banned from speaking ecologies because
the students don't agree with them
all these people you're seeing here have
at some stage been d platformed at
oxford at cambridge at king's college
london university of sydney stanford
yale harvard even berkeley once home to
the most famous free speech movement in
the world they've all cancelled speakers
over protests by their students when did
the brightest and best turn into the
wettest and the wokest
colleges and universities are supposed
to be a breeding ground for
intellectuals the place where great
ideas are seeded where genius flourishes
where discussion tests and stretches the
boundaries of human understanding
debates shouldn't come with a helpline
if you get to the end of higher
education you haven't heard an idea you
didn't already agree with you've wasted
your time and money that's the whole
point of going there so sorry snowflake
students the world's a tough challenging
place campus isn't supposed to be a safe
space from ideas it's supposed to be a
safe space for ideas so get used to it
get debating and grow up
and for freedom of speech to freedom of
movement the british government is
failing horribly to tackle the deadly
and desperately sad surge of migrants
reaching the country by boat more than 7
000 people have sailed illegally to the
uk this year alone that's more than
triple the number by this time last year
many of them are being trafficked by
vile people smuggling gangs who extort
the migrants and then send them to risk
their lives in perilous dinghies dozens
have tragically died on these crossings
it's dangerous it's wrong and it has to
stop but the government's plan to spend
120 million pounds flying thousands of
migrants on a one-way ticket to rwanda
is ridiculous and inhuman migrants who
make it to rwanda if any of them end up
actually doing so will either be offered
permanent residency there or sent back
to where they came from none even if
they qualify to be asylum seekers in the
uk will ever end up in the united
kingdom
the plan's already collapsing into fast
there have been six legal challenges and
the first flights are now months away at
best and i'm not surprised the uk
government has itself criticized
rwanda's human rights record
the migrant crossings are a crisis which
has got to be fixed we can all agree on
that but this rwanda fiasco smacks of
headline grabbing tokenism it's
unfeasible it's unfair it's unworkable
and by denying real asylum seekers help
it's not british it's supposed to be a
deterrent but it clearly isn't working
but perhaps there is a simpler way to
resolve this there is currently a deeply
unpleasant highly treacherous shark
patrolling the waters of the english
channel
so the french naval vessel is now a long
way inside english waters don't they
know it's brexit
i say we keep nigel farage out there on
his little yellow dinghy that should be
enough to put anybody off coming into
the united kingdom
now there are plenty of reasons why some
people still prefer to work from home
maybe you have a long boring commute
just a waste of your time or money
perhaps you don't want to squander a
fortune on dodgy sandwiches and frothing
coffees with silly names maybe your
colleagues are incredibly irritating we
can all relate to that
but according to employees at apple
working from the office also makes you a
sexist and racist obviously 76 percent
of apple workers said an anonymous
survey that they're unhappy with the
company's return to work policy and a
group of disgruntled staffers have now
written a long letter to bosses about it
saying that the tech giant is favoring
privileged staff by demanding they come
back to work declaring the shift back
will make the company whiter
and more male dominated they also said
the requirement to actually turn up the
world was being driven by the company's
fear of the future of work well i'm
sorry i think it's pretty clear who has
got the fear of work in the future here
it's these pathetic spineless employees
at apple of course they want to stay
working at home means they can slob
around on their sofas swinging their
kale lattes munching their quinoa salads
smashing their avocados killing billions
of bees search social media for things
to be offended by you're not saving the
planet wokies or smashing the patriarchy
you're just lazy work shy waste trolls
get back to work
you